the final terrifying moments for 176
passengers and crew on board
Ukrainian Airlines Boeing 737 for days
Iranian officials denied it had been
shot down by one of their missiles but
on Saturday Iran's Revolutionary Guard
delivered this dramatic u-turn it is us
who are to blame the plane was on its
way it did not have any error or mistake
everyone worked very well efficiently it
was us who made a mistake and we are
responsible we should accept
responsibility and accountability the
[Applause]
belated admission has sparked protests
in Tehran they chant death to liars and
shameless as they demand those
responsible for the missile strike to be
brought to justice they're angry about
the downing of the plane and they want
accountability from the authorities less
than 24 hours before Saturday's
admission the head of iran's Civil
Aviation Organization spoke to Al
Jazeera it is very obvious that it was
not hit by a missile if a missile hit it
it should have crashed in its original
direction
and this is what's causing more anger
among Iranians the fact that it took
officials more than 48 hours after
repeated denials to reveal what really
happened there was also criticism when
debris from the wreckage was moved from
the crash site possibly tainting
evidence the announcement comes a day
after Iran gave a Ukrainian team access
to the planes black boxes evidence that
could be crucial for putting together a
timeline a group of international
aviation experts is now part of the
Iranian investigation but this case
could complicate further a region that's
already in crisis the head of Iran's
judiciary has asked for all the evidence
to be handed over to be investigated and
the man in charge of Iran's
Revolutionary Guards will be briefing
MPs in a closed-door session in
Parliament but what is not clear is how
this will impact Iran's military and its
government in the future
doors of d'bari al jazeera Tehran